قيل في قانون الحفاظ على العلاقات راويه
انما يحدث في الداخل لا يجب ان يذاع للعلم
لكن هذا ما لم يستطع نظام الايراني الحفاظ
عليه نتحدث عن اروقه البيت الواحد الذي
اخترقته وكاله ايران انترنال وكشفت
المستور حول نشر سريه اعدتها وكاله انباء
فارس الايرانيه الرسميه للقائد العام
الايراني للحرس الثوري الايراني حسين
سلامي بعد ان وقعت بايدي مجموعه هاكرز
تدعى بلاك ريورد
123 صفحه تحدثت بالحقيقه بعيدا عن ما
تبديه تصريحات الرسميه للنظام الايراني
عنوانها ان الاحتجاجات لن تنتهي قريبا ولن
تتوقف اقوال هذه النشره السريه ماخوذه عن
لسان المرشد علي خمنائي الذي افصح لسلامه
عن مخاوفه بشان التظاهرات فقد راى المرشد
ان النظام بات متاخرا عن الركب في الحرب
الاعلاميه للتعتيني عما يجري وايهام
المدنيين بانها مؤامره غربيه تصريح حمل
اعترافا ضمينيا بان النظام يواجه ثوره
حقيقيه ويعاني شيخوخه مترهله من قمه
سلطاته وصولا الى القاعده وليس انتهاء
بقوه البسيج التي وصفها خامنئي بغير
الفعاله وبالعاجز عن التعبئه لوقف
الاحتجاجات الشعبيه لم تتوقف الاقرارات
هنا فحسب بل ان الارقام ايضا تعرضت
للتلاعب واظهار محدوديه الاحتجاجات فبينما
تضج الشوارع بست 100,000 من المتظاهرين
تحول الرقم الى مجرد 40,000 في التصريحات
القضائيه وكشفت الوثيقه ايضا ان 70% من
الايرانيين لا يرغبون اطلاقا في الخروج في
تظاهرات داعمه للنظام وان الروس زود
السلطات الايرانيه بنتائج التنصت الاقليمي
لاجهزه المخابرات الاجنبيه على ايران
[موسيقى]